ready to sing and dance to the hits
million dollar reunion is performing at
the Grand Event Center at Green Valley
Ranch this weekend and we have a few of
the performers here with us we have
Bobby Taylor and Cole thank you guys so
much for being here it's wonderful
wonderful and this live audience I'm
telling you right our fans are here sit
down they all came just for you guys
well I love that both of you live here
locally in Las Vegas so let's talk about
the show this weekend what can we expect
from it Bobby I'll start with you well
uh it's what it is is the former cast
members of The Million Dollar Quartet
and we're not doing the play we're
paying tribute to the music of Sun
Records which many consider the Big Bang
of rock and roll and uh you know we do
it with a lot of enthusiasm and energy
because this music calls for it so you
know it's rockabilly is what they kind
of call it yeah and that's characterized
by a lot of maniacal energy and
Showmanship so we we bring that and we
salute the music and it's all about the
music and the Showmanship well how fun
is that honey Million Dollar Quartet was
one of my favorite shows here in Las
Vegas so I'm excited that we're kind of
keeping that going and Cole what Drew
you in to this show now and what are you
excited for people to see well I tell
you so we we did almost four years at
Harris we made out of quartet when that
show closed a bunch of us went on the
road and did the show like a you know
touring the show in different parts of
the country well we came up with this
concept right here of doing like a stars
of The Million Dollar Quartet we don't
we don't have the play factor it's just
a rock and roll concert but it's all the
stars of the mdq and it's just a it's a
lot of fun and people out on the road
have been loving it so we're excited to
be here in Vegas and so technically it's
not an impersonation show it's more so
just a tribute to the classics right
absolutely we're in the spirit of I mean
we're out there we're we're doing the
songs and the styles of and stuff but
we're not coming out in the jumpsuits or
anything like that but uh we give a
pretty skirted uh rendition of the music
Bobby you got the glasses on you're
ready you're ready for the show you're
in character I'm ready can't wait for
Saturday night looking forward to it we
have a good local following here
and uh looking forward to seeing
everybody out there really do you have a
favorite moment that happens on stage or
something you're really excited for the
audience to see uh me personally yeah I
just I think the whole show is just
wonderful you know
I think there's going to be a special
moment for Jerry Lee Lewis this time
around a little hint here because of his
recent passing and the gentleman we have
Jacob Tolliver that does Jerry Lee is
fantastic it's almost his adopted son
really so that's that that's going to be
a poignant moment I think absolutely
well some incredible talent that will be
on the stage you guys are holding down
the fort here in Vegas but you said you
have other band members kind of coming
in from all over right all over the
country we got Evan Buckley Harris who's
a Las Vegas local as well he'll be here
and we've got Jacob Toliver who's you
know American Idol and all that kind of
stuff Mike and Earl Goodman we just got
a great cast we're really excited to
have oh we're so excited for the show
you guys will have to come back and see
us and tell us how it went but you guys
got to see the show million dollar
reunion is happening this Saturday at
The Grand Event Center inside Green
Valley Ranchos